on l'a vu avec toutes les les crises que
nous avons affronté j'allais dire les
unes après les autres au cours des
dernières années
euh personne ne s'attendait à à à la
crise de la covid on a réussi à trouver
les moyens pour lutter contre pour
devenir en quelques mois du reste la
pharmacie Du Monde euh vacciner
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens mais aussi
plus de 100 pays euh on a su trouver les
moyens euh de
résister aux conséquences et notamment
aux conséquences économiques et sociale
avec le programme next generation eu où
effectivement nous avons émis de la
dette en commun pour protéger l'ensemble
du secteur économique des fermetures
administratives j'allais dire qui était
la conséquence du covid on a su trouver
les moyens également pour la crise de
l'énergie conséquence de l'agression de
Vladimir Poutine en Russie donc donc là
ça veut dire que les les les
États-membres sont prêts à
nouveau mon message mon message c'est
que l'Europe elle fonctionne de mieux en
mieux en ayant conscience des problèmes
à affronter
euh en se donnant ensuite les moyens de
les surmonter donc le problème
maintenant il est clair le problème et
notamment ce qui concerne la défense
c'est l'agression de Vladimir Poutine en
Ukraine on le sait c'est évidemment
l'Ukraine évidemment qui est en première
ligne de façon absolument admirable mais
c'est nous qui sommes en seconde ligne
c'est nous qui sommes visés donc oui
bien sûr il faut augmenter notre
capacité d'industrie de défense ensemble
et c'est tout le projet que je porte
alors avec une vision peut-être de j'ai
évoquer une centaine de milliards
d'euros qu'il faudrait peut-être mettre
sur la table euh si les États-membres
sont d'accord on sera trouver les
moyens